Mẹ mẹ bà thông mười, ngoài trường ngào, sẽ gửi la rope lên tiếng bắt bỏ tiền đồn cho rằng
cư tổng thống xíri ởng bà xa an a sát bị đầu động khi đàn tị nạn tại Mác Cơva.
Ông khẳng định ông A sát và gia đình vực an toàn khoải máy và không cố vụ đầu động nào sảy ra.
Ông la rope cho biết thêm, ngào cấp cuy chế tị nạn trong A sát và người thân vì lý dọng nhìn đạo.
Sau khi họ đối mắt nhiều mùa đezo an đình kể từ khi chính quyền đã mắt tiền nghiệm xúc đồ vào cuy năm ngoại.
Ông bà sát an a sát lập cửa thống xíri trong 2.5 và la đônguink của Mác Cơva.
Chính quyền của ông bị lực lượng đối lập hay át tày in a sám lập lầu và tháng 12 năm, hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành thư và sẵn đỏ ông phải sang ngà sinh sống.
Gần đây, đại Washington quyền xíri sau hà mô tổ chức phía trình buồn có chủ sở tả anh cho biết,
ông a sát tình như việc ở Mác Cơva sau một vụ đầu động sẽ ra hồi tháng chiến.
Mặc dù thông tin này không được sát hực nhưng lại đặc biệt vời chủ y vả nhánh trong lần chuyển trên các phương tiện chuyển thông phương tay
Bởi mắt sơ vả từ nhiều lần bị cá vôk, liên quan đến các vụ đầu nọc nhắm vào chính khác và cá nhân mặc tư tổn lập
Ví dụ như cụ điều viên xác ngày xí quý pan hay nhà họ đâu alic xây nè và đi
Fíng á luôn phụ nhận mọi cá vôk, dưới phân tích nhận đến việc mắt sơ vả phản ứng nhăng với tiên đầu nơi này
Nhằm chẳng tạo thêm căng thẳng trong thời điểm ngà bất vui trị hiện diện quan sức và hỏa động nhân đạo tại xíri